Touted as the most popular Asian destination for vegan travelers,...
...Taipei has deep roots in Buddhist culture,...
...perhaps one of the factors...
...that influence the rise of veganism in the city.
Though there is no rule in Buddhism about avoiding meat,...
...many choose a more compassionate approach to food consumption.
The city hosts over 50 plant-based restaurants...
...that feature local foods and international cuisine,...
...from vegan street food to a full-fledged vegan supermarket.
Berlin gets major credit for embodying the vegan lifestyle.
Despite Germany's long history of consuming cured meats,...
...a culture shift is taking place in the capital city.
Lovingly dubbed Vegan Berlin, the city offers vegan clothing stores...
...that focus on sustainable and fair-trade fashion,...
...several vegan grocery stores...
...and close to 500 vegan and veg-friendly restaurants.
Bristol ranks number one.
With its incredible range of independent plant-based cafes and restaurants,...
...residents can choose between a wide variety of vegan fares,...
...like Oowee Diner that features vegan versions of meaty junk food.
There's also Vx Bristol,...
Excitement is real; we're at Vx Bristol, which has amazing vegan junk food.
Look at what I'm about to dive into: the Monster Shake.
I don't even know how to...
...Bun Fiction and Cafe Fino.
There's also a vegan co-working space and monthly vegan event.
Community website Vegan Bristol shares a collection of vegan,...
...vegetarian and veg-friendly business listings by neighborhood,...
...including restaurants, breweries, natural health practitioners...
...and a vending machine service that provides chilled vegan food.